[Musique]
moi j'ai pas de bruit je suis le shérif
qu'il casimir et je vais surprendre le
bandit bill françois attention aux les
mains tu es prix ne pousse plus je me
rends chez les flip casimir je me rends
mais comment est-ce que tu m'a reconnu
et parce que dans toute l'île aux
enfants il n'y a qu'une seule personne
qui soit capable de dire où les noces
c'est toi casimir consul amita la
panoplie de chérif ça alors quand tu as
aussi fort que quand charlotte - mas le
plus grand détective du monde
mais ce petit casino il est pas si
stupide que sa tâche qu'est ce que tu
dis non rien du tout ben je t'ai entendu
parler écouter les miens je disais que
de plus dures je peux baisser les mains
or si tu veux toute façon maintenant le
logeant le jeu est terminé tu nous a
reconnu alors dans casimir tu es déçu
mais oui personne n'a jamais peur dans
leur style et dont moi je trouve que
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
je suis contente de vouloir gens ne
l'est que se passe-t-il en direct la
part oui un peu je viens d'entendre un
très étrange oiseau sifflet de l'eau ma
fenêtre
bonjour comment était-il et cet oiseau
non je n'en sais rien c'est pas regarder
mais jamais je n'avais entendu un oiseau
sifflet de la saur sarlat qui est
étrange mais c'est peut-être une bonne
occasion pour après sherlock mollema le
grand détective as as tu une idée
non non non non non mais j'ai une
meilleure idée bon alors ça c'est bien
la première fois au coude que du mur je
t'en prie tutoient leur grave c'est
vraiment pas le moment de nous
chamailler jetaient sur de bons dans le
kiosque de givry tête voilà voilà voilà
une cassette avec des chants d'oiseaux
l'écouté avec vous ne l'êtes vous nous
direz quel est le champ que vous avez
entendu les enfants nous dirons le nom
de l'oiseau
parce c'est vrai que c'est le let les
enfants font parfois aussi fort que
sherlock moins long mais ce n'est pas ce
qui est bon les enfants s'en venait rené
le legs pas besoin de vous venez vite
voilà que ça va nous aider à trouver le
nom de l'oiseau mystérieux de lolita
autres q vous êtes d'accord
et vous si chez vous écoutez bien s'ils
vous nous regardez souvent et un certain
nombre de chants d'oiseaux vous avez
déjà entendu
écoutez bien voilà le premier c'est un
coach qui était son collègue et non
alors un autre maintenant
c'est presque sa voix quoi c'est pas une
tourterelle c'est un pigeon or fait
presque pareil presque pareil et à
saint-thélo non t'es pas un pigeon
bombay j'en ai c'est un autre alors
écoutons c'est joli ça c'est pas un
rossignol
qu'est ce que c'est casimir d'une idée
non non ça je ne vois pas mais c'est pas
un rouge gorge c'est un merlin un merle
noir
c'était une arme non non non lola et
écoute moi est ce que ton l'oiseau ne
faisait pas ce bruit là mais le payant
les enfants kazim excusez-moi 120
camions et coûteux excusez mon opinion
mais sérieusement c'est une chouette
etait-ce une chouette c'était pas si
c'était pas ça écouter qu'à une autre
proposition nous faire kazimiyah temps
c'était peut-être un maçon qui faisait
ce bruit là je te parle d'oiseaux les
enfants le dernier tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure
écoutons voilà c'est un vrai signal
était ce un rossignol du tout non
c'était pas ça l'écouté ils ont fait
aussi bien de votre aide à les jouer
maintenant je suis navré l'honnête moi
j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai pu
écoutez je l'inventé comptage du stif
les noms d'oiseaux tiens ça me semble
être un drôle d'oiseau st oui et moi il
me semble connaître c'est oiseaux là
bonjour tout le monde j'apprends que la
zoé alors j'ai pas le temps de m'arrêter
parce que j'ai beaucoup de travail de
mots semblaient bien joué aujourd'hui
pour sûr que j'ai un petit air qui nous
trotte dans la tête depuis ce matin je
n'arrête pas de le siffler à l'aller les
torts les contrôles ecc6 ça c'est un
oiseau
alors moi je suis un kangourou 6 mai